[Musik]
Bürger und Wirtschaft sind erleichtert
alle drei Atomkraftwerke laufen weiter
bis längstens zum
15.4.2023 der Kanzler berief sich auf
seine Richtlinienkompetenz erstmals in
der Ampelkoalition die grüne Basis ihr
habt dies irritiert während sich
FDP-Parteichef Christian Lindner in
seinem Kampf für längere Laufzeiten bis
2024 bestätigt sieht ist das jetzt die
Wende das wollen wir heute abend
besprechen mit diesen Gästen Fritz
fahren heute eher Chemiker Buchautor und
Hochschullehrer in 90er Jahren bei
Umweltsenator in Hamburg anschließend
bei verschiedenen Energiekonzernen tätig
damit also geballte energieexpertise
heute abend Karl Julius Kronberg ist
FDP-Politiker und deutsche Unternehmer
seine Forderung jetzt muss alles ans
Netz damit folgt er wohl der parteiline
ich bin gespannt auch mit von der Partie
dr Gerhard Konrad er ist ehemaliger
Direktor Bundesnachrichtendienst Spion
und Islamwissenschaftler er wird heute
Abend über den Ukraine Krieg sprechen
ich hoffe jedoch auch noch ein bisschen
etwas über Spionage zu lernen Ludmilla
ist Politikwissenschaftlerin und Ukraine
Expertin des Instituts für europäische
Politik sie ist sich sicher die Rhetorik
um die nato-bedrohung lenkt ab und mein
Name ist Lena schick ich freue mich
heute Abend ihre Gastgeberin sein zu
dürfen das Thema über das heute jeder
Deutsche eigentlich spricht bewegt auch
mich das Kanzler Machtwort was mich
nämlich verwundert ist so ein bisschen
der grüne Wirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck der empfindet jetzt nämlich die
von Scholz getroffene Entscheidung als
ein Weg mit dem ich gut arbeiten und
leben kann das sagt der Habeck auf jeden
Fall am Montagabend in den Tagesthemen
das klang auf dem Parteitag der Grünen
am 14 Oktober nur drei Tage vor dem
kanzlerums nun ja ein ganz wenig anders
hören wir doch mal rein
wahrscheinlich ist es auch nicht falsch
zu vermuten dass die Botschaft
eigentlich war geht doch zurück zu
Atomkraft das ist falsch und das wird
auf keinen Fall mit uns passieren nicht
mit der Bundesregierung nicht mit den
Grünen in der Bundesregierung und nicht
mit Steffi und nicht mit mir
ja das verstehe ich jetzt nicht so ganz
erfahren heute verstehen sie das oder
sind die Grünen eigentlich wenn man es
platt sagt ein wenig verlogen ja das
haben wir doch schon das ganze Jahr
feststellen können
und wenn man sich anschaut welches was
die Wirkung jetzt dieses Machtwort des
Kanzlers ist wir gucken ja aus in der
Industrie jeden Tag und sie Strompreise
an und seit gestern ist der Strompreis
um 10 Euro Cent gesungen das zeigt uns
was uns dieses gehampelte der Grünen in
diesem Jahr eigentlich gekostet hat ja
es war gestern noch 30 Cent jetzt sind
es 20 Cent in der Spitze und wenn ich
das mal so hochrechne darf man einen
nicht tun aber ich tue das mal auf ein
Jahr hoch Rechner reden wir über 50
Milliarden 50 Milliarden
die Grünen haben uns 50 Milliarden
natürlich weil ja am Ende das fing doch
an mit wir haben keinen Stromproblem
dann hörten wir streckbetrieb geht nicht
funktioniert nicht bringt nichts dann
wurde gesagt zwei Kernkraftwerke und
dann im niedersächsischen Wahl
wurde wurden die Bürger hinter die
Fichte geführt das hat dann ja auch
geklappt und jetzt ist auf einmal alles
wieder gut und am Ende muss man
feststellen 50 Milliarden weniger in den
Taschen der Bürger und der Unternehmen
und das kostet Arbeitsplätze am Ende es
kostet unsere Arbeitsplätze weil wir
konkurrieren ja mit Strompreisen in
Amerika von 2 Euro Cent und in China von
3 € sind und deswegen muss man jetzt
schon sagen
diese allgemeine Zufriedenheit die sich
da jetzt so breit macht
da muss man auch ein bisschen vor warnen
denn
das reicht hinten und vorne nicht ja
darüber sprechen wir auch gleich noch
wir bleiben einmal noch bei Herrn
Harbeck Herr Kronberg da frage ich jetzt
natürlich sie als FDP-Politiker sie
haben jetzt bestimmt große Freude daran
sich über die Grünen aufzuregen sind
aber ja mit denen eine Ampel aber meine
Frage ist bleibt dabei ist diese
Götterdämmerung bei den Grünen jetzt
nicht eigentlich scheinheilig also
erstmal Frau Schink freue ich mich nicht
das wäre sicherlich fehl am Platz ich
freue mich über die Entscheidung
Bundeskanzlers das ganz sicher die
freuen sich nicht dass man ein kleines
Machtwort mit den Grünen gesprochen
wurde naja also wir haben sehr
unterschiedliche Ausgangspositionen FDP
und Grüne in dieser Frage das ist
richtig aber uns eint auch die
Überzeugung dass es falsch wäre zurück
in die Atomkraft zu gehen
wir sprechen ja jetzt nicht von einem
zurück in die Atomkraft sondern von dem
Weiterbetrieb für vier Monate das ist
das was der Kanzler jetzt entschieden
hat in ihnen schlagen ja wahrscheinlich
zwei Herzen das politikerherzen das
unternehmerherz würde ich jetzt mal
jetzt hören wir einmal auf Verfahren
heute der gesagt hat 50 Milliarden das
ist ja eine ganze Menge Geld als
Unternehmer sagen Sie also immer noch
nicht dass die Grünen vielleicht doch
ein bisschen auf dem Holzweg sind
wir haben die Frage nach dem
Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke anders
beurteilt wir haben gefordert dass sie
weiter betrieben werden und so
Forderungen gingen auch darüber hinaus
was der Kratzer jetzt entschieden hat
insofern ist es auf jeden Fall ein guter
Kompromiss der gefunden wurde und damit
kommen wir über den Winter und wir
werden im Frühjahr schauen wie es
weitergeht da ist jetzt überhaupt keine
Notwendigkeit der Entscheidung zu
treffen oder fordern früher finden
können also und dann die 50 Milliarden
vielleicht für Pflege wir haben ganz
viele Felder in Deutschland offen sind
naja also ob die 50 Milliarden wirklich
so gespart worden wären das vermag ich
nicht zu beurteilen die der Strompreis
bildet sich auch nach dem sogenannten
Marit order Prinzip und die teuerste
Energiequelle das war ganz Strom war Gas
und die Gaspreise sind sehr sehr hoch
gewesen sind auch schon stark wieder
zurückgelaufen aber
sie hätten ein Stück weit niedriger
bleiben können wenn Frank
Kohlekraftwerke wenn man mehr oder mehr
Atomstrom zusätzlich einmal gehabt hätte
das ist schon richtig aber ich kann das
nicht in Euro Ziffern und im übrigen
ganz ehrlich es wäre auch vergossene
Milch es ist Schneefang gestern nicht
also ihr fahrt
oh ja selbstverständlich
wir haben natürlich im letzten Jahr im
Wahlkampf noch eine andere Konstellation
bevorzugt besprochen aber die stand ja
nicht zur Verfügung nach dem Wahltermin
und insofern ist es vollkommen richtig
dass wir jetzt aus der Mitte der
Gesellschaft heraus und aus der Mitte
der politischen Positionen heraus
Regierungspolitik mitgestalten können
das ist der Anspruch den wir vor der
Wahl angekündigt haben den wir haben und
den setzen wir jetzt durch und um es ist
ja auch eine gute Entscheidung gefallen
zu wechseln also ganze wohlwand hat hier
noch nie ein FDP-Politiker über die
Grünen gesprochen aber das überlasse ich
natürlich ihnen ist natürlich nett für
die Grünen auch
ein Parteitag ist ja nun auch nicht der
verlängerte Arm einer
Regierungskonstellation es ist sogar
wichtig dass auf Parteitagen die
Positionen der Parteien deutlich werden
damit man dann im Regierungsgeschäft
Kompromisse schließt so funktioniert
unsere Demokratie das ist anders als in
China wo der Parteitag irgendwie
klatscht vor der niedersachsenwahl
genauso da müssen die Grünen Wähler
sicher jetzt schon fragen ob sie da
vielleicht die Kehrtwende nicht ganz so
gerne mitgemacht hätten die
Niedersachsen Wahl wurde nicht an der
entlang der Atomkraft Frage entschieden
die wurde aber definitiv da besprochen
es war ja nicht so als hätte man gesagt
wir können ihn da nichts versprechen wir
sagen dazu nichts gemeint die Grünen
plakatiert mit AKW bye bye das kann ich
noch sehen weil ich bin in Hamburg
Nachbarstaat und damit haben sie
Wahlkampf gemacht und haben natürlich
dann auch ihr Klientel an die Urne
gebracht
das waren klares Votum denen die gerne
Energie bin aber doch ein bisschen
anderer Auffassung
zu Kernenergie die ganze ganz Europa
geht zurück in die Kerne Energie
Schweden überlegt die schon abgestellten
Kernkraftwerke wieder zu reaktivieren
auch das Stück für uns gut zu Gesichte
wir haben noch drei Kernkraftwerke
deaktiviert werden können und die
Schweiz macht weiter Belgien hat wieder
aktiviert Holland will drei neue polen
will zwei neue wir sind da wirklich die
Geisterfahrer und man muss sich schon
fragen
will ja bis 2024 immerhin verlängern ja
das ist ja schon mal vernünftiger Anfang
weil wir doch wissen die Gaskrise wird
doch nicht im nächsten Frühjahr beendet
sein wir werden doch mit Ach und Krach
vielleicht mit den Speichern auskommen
wahrscheinlich eher nicht wenn es einen
kalten Winter gibt
aber dann werden die Speicher leer sein
und dann werden sie nicht mehr
aufgefüllt wir dürfen nicht vergessen
wir haben bis August diesen Jahres immer
noch die gazprom-leitung gehabt die den
die die Speicher mitgefüllt haben das
heißt wir werden im nächsten Jahr im
September anfangen mit halben
gastspeichern und in der Situation zu
sagen oh tut ja nichts dazu wir machen
einfach so weiter und stellen die
Kernkraftwerke ab und der Fehler ist das
dann Gaskraftwerke tatsächlich als
teuerste da haben sie völlig richtig den
Preis bilden und deswegen müsste man
eigentlich jetzt sagen Gas hat in der
Verstromung überhaupt nichts mehr zu
suchen das muss er raus und wir wissen
ja aus der alten sozial-liberalen
Koalition und der Helmut Schmidt dass
die Kernkraftwerke in Deutschland so die
sind designt worden sind so ausgelegt
worden sind dass sie ganz schnell hoch
und runter fahren können die können
nachts runterfahren wie nichts anderes
viel besser als Kohle viel besser sogar
als Gas das vergisst man immer wieder
das heißt die ideale Ergänzung auch für
erneuerbare die wir ja alle wollen
erneuerbare Wind und Sonne heißt die
Kernenergie darüber muss man mal
diskutieren in dieser Gesellschaft Herr
Konrad als Bürger wenn ich sie frage wie
sehen Sie denn die Kehrtwende der Grünen
von den maximalpositionen jetzt zu einem
ersten Kompromiss innerhalb der der
ampelch Koalition zu kommen ich sehe
allerdings die Energiefrage aus der
nachrichtendienstliche Sicht auch noch
mal ein bisschen anders nicht nicht
fröhlicher ehrlich gesagt denn wir
argumentieren derzeit ja nur mit dem
Status Quo das heißt also wenn
unterstellen dass die Energieversorgung
so wie sie jetzt mit Ach und Krach
hergestellt worden ist dass sie so
bleibt jetzt denken sie bitteschön daran
dass wir das schöne Wort Hybride
Bedrohungen haben dass wir jetzt seit
Wochen die Händeringen und den Schutz
der kritischen Infrastruktur in den
Vordergrund stellen ja vor wem denn ja
nicht von vor den Umweltaktivisten sage
ich jetzt mal sondern letzten Endes und
das hat gestern übrigens haben die drei
nachrichtendienstchefs auch bei der
öffentlichen Anhörung vor dem
parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium für
alle Bürger auch sehr deutlich gesagt
das Risiko einer horizontalen Eskalation
des ukraine-konflikts nicht nur für die
Ukraine sondern auch für die
Unterstützer starten und eben auch für
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland er
besteht auch darin dass man im Winter
mal da oder dort nicht nur eine
Energiequelle einschränkt sagt man ganz
vorsichtig
das ist durchaus möglich das hat durch
entsprechende entweder an welche
Energiequellen denken sie da konkret
Kraftwerke abstellen zum Beispiel oder
Sie haben ja Nord Stream gehabt ohne
jetzt die Urheberschaft schon
präjudizieren zu wollen nicht aber Sie
können ja selbstverständlich andere
zulieferleitungen oder Sie können
Steuersysteme etc pp können sie ja durch
entweder mit der Cyber Network attack
oder aber eben mit ganz normaler
Sabotage als analoger als Sabotage
können sie ja das auch mal flachlegen
und dass die Dinge aufgeklärt worden
sind jetzt auch deutlich vor dem Ukraine
Krieg und relativ leicht aufklärbar sind
sollten wir auch nicht vergessen sie
können fast alle in kritische
Infrastruktur inzwischen im Internet
Recherche aus anderen Gründen der
Transparenz nicht da der
Bürgerbeteiligung der
Raumordnungsverfahren
sie ist sie ist einfach da sie ist da
und sie hängt ab vom Kriegsverlauf in
der Ukraine sie dürfen nicht vergessen
wir kommen ja später sowieso noch drauf
dass ich mein Putin und designen werden
diesen Krieg nicht verlieren wollen
und solange sie diesen Krieg nicht
verlieren wollen werden sie wenn sie im
Felde wenn sie wollen nicht siegen
können danach sitzt derzeit ja gar nicht
richtig aus wenn Sie horizontal
eskalieren das sehen wir jetzt im
Augenblick schon bei der Ukraine nennt
man an den Fronten kann man nichts
bewirken also macht man jetzt genau das
man schädigt die Infrastruktur die
kritische Infrastruktur der Ukraine und
wenn natürlich
bedauerlicherweise richtig gezählt hat
nicht erzählt ungefähr 30% der Zeit der
der Energieversorgung der Ukraine in den
letzten 10 Tagen durch russische
Luftangriffe zerstört ja eine Reaktion
auf die Krim nein ach so nein das war
ein netter Anlass da kann man aber nicht
richtig informiert bin sind gerade 1100
Ortschaften ohne Strom aber Frau mannig
das wissen sie vermutlich noch besser
eigentlich ich kann nur bestätigen dass
30 Prozent der Energieinfrastrukturen
wurden bestätigt und die Raketen
Angriffe ein Teil davon er hat die
Ukraine schon geschafft zu reparieren
aber eigentlich nicht alles kann man tun
und zum Beispiel gestern hat die
jugendkraine
34 Drohnen erlebt die dann attackiert
wurden 30 davon hatten zum Ziel nur Kiew
25 wurden dann von der ukrainischen
Armee abgeschossen und dieser Terror dem
jetzt die Ukraine ja ausgeliefert ist
dass es nicht nur der Anfang sozusagen
das wird fortgesetzt und in Zukunft wird
Russland alles tun und wirklich die
Infrastruktur noch mal stärker zu
beschädigen
das werden wir heute auch noch im näher
vertiefen sie selbst sind ja in der
Ukraine geboren jetzt leben sie ja in
Deutschland wenn sie sich das Kanzler
Machtwort heute anschauen wie haben Sie
darüber empfunden
das Kanzler Machtwort das erst
weiterlaufen lässt in Deutschland
mit Blick auf die Atomkraftwerke ich
glaube ich habe jetzt der Diskussion
zugehört ich muss sagen die Politik muss
immer den Kontext berücksichtigen und
Flexibilität zeigen man kann ich kann
mir vorstellen das was man eigentlich im
Programm sich vorgenommen hat muss man
auch in der Lage sein an den Kontext
anzupassen und mit Blick mit Blick auf
die Atomkraftwerke ich glaube keiner
konnte sich in Deutschland so was
vorstellen aber ich näher als Außenseite
weil ich mich eher mit der Ukraine
beschäftige muss ich sagen die Politik
muss auch in der Lage sein den Kontexte
und neu Gegebenheiten zu berücksichtigen
und dementsprechend sich anzupassen wir
haben in Deutschland auch insbesondere
ein Problem mit dem vertrauen wir haben
immer einen immer größeren
Vertrauensverlust in die Politik und ihr
Thema erfahren heute könnte man damit ja
eigentlich ganz gut verknüpfen das
vielleicht auch die Politik Fehler macht
ja wir haben eine ganze Reihe von
Fehlern gemacht das ist wohl wahr und
in einer solchen Krise wird natürlich
das Vertrauen auf die Probe gestellt und
insofern ist es jetzt ganz wichtig
glaube ich dass dieses gehampelt was wir
jetzt hatten die jetzt Ampel Gehampel
dass das jetzt mal zu Ende ist
das reicht natürlich hinten und vorne
nicht wie bereits gesagt habe weil sie
müssen sehen dass draußen die
der Mittelstand und die Industrie jeden
Tag kämpfen um den Erhalt der
Arbeitsplätze und es wird in jedem Tag
schwerer gemacht da hilft uns nun schon
und das schafft auch ein bisschen Ruhe
die Ansage dass der Deckel bei Gas auf
12 Euro Cent festgesetzt wird und für
die Industrie auf 7 Euro Cent ich war
wie gesagt USA 3 Euro Cent oder 2 Euro
Cent und China 3 und gegen die treten
wir ja an
das hat schon geholfen nur wir müssen
natürlich wissen dass Ende wir nicht
jedes Jahr 200 Milliarden auf dem Tisch
legen können das wird dieser Staat nicht
aussagen das wird uns zu einer
Verschuldung führen dass wir
sozusagen an eine Weichwährung bekommen
mit dabei beitragen und deswegen müssen
wir dringend
die Angebote an Energie in Deutschland
verändern wir haben uns zu lange auf
Russland verlassen das war ja eine
Politik die die von grün bis schwarz
sozusagen angesagt war wir machen
Windenergie und jeder wusste hinter
jeder Windenergieanlage steht ein
Gaskraftwerk das muss es tun weil wenn
der Wind nicht da ist muss der Strom ja
auffließen also muss man flexible
Kraftwerke hinzuschalten können und das
war immer Gaskraftwerk das hat auch die
neue Ampel gesagt wir wollten 30
Gaskraftwerke bauen ja ich frage mich
woher und deswegen müssen wir die Frage
weiterhin tiefer stellen wir müssten
jetzt mal wirklich auch
in die eigenen
Erzeugungen herangehen das heißt das
Fracking was man machen kann in
Niedersachsen in Sachsen-Anhalt
Niedersachsen wird es jetzt nichts weil
da ist Rot-Grün dran da wird erstmal
fünf Jahre
keine neue technologische Innovation
angegangen ich sage auch die heimische
Braunkohle kann man grün machen man kann
das CO2 abschneiden das heißt das sind
die Aufgaben auch keine energielaufzeit
verlängern wir müssen uns mit der
eigenen Braunkohle beschäftigen und sie
sauber machen das kann man nämlich der
norwegische Ministerpräsident hat uns
das angeboten hat gesagt ihr könnt das
CO2 zu mir geben ich bring das in die in
die Tiefsee und wir müssen das eigene
Erdgas fördern nur dann kommen wir raus
so dieses Gehampel man drei Monate
wieder mal ein bisschen Kernenergie und
dann gucken wir mal weiter das ist doch
keine Lösung das heißt wir müssen da wir
können dann 200 Milliarden rechtfertigen
wenn das eine Brücke ist in eine
Energiezukunft die wir dann wieder alle
Vertrauen haben
wenn ich jetzt hier so zuhöre muss ich
so ein bisschen denken die Regierung hat
den ernste Lage doch nicht erkannt
Grundwerk meine ich doch Hexe doch der
Ernst der Lage ist uns absolut bewusst
es geht um die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit die
internationale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
deutschen Wirtschaft wir haben starken
Mittelstand und starken industriellen
Mittelstand eine Säule unserer
Volkswirtschaft ist die Industrie viel
mehr als die USA das beispielsweise
haben oder auch andere Länder und wir
sind Exportweltmeister wir sind abhängig
von der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer
Unternehmen auf den Weltmärkten und wir
sind in der schwersten Energiekrise seit
Bestehen der Bundesrepublik da gibt es
überhaupt keinen Zweifel und ich stimme
mir ein paar Arnold ausdrücklich zu wenn
er die Frage aufmacht
wir haben doch Gas wir haben Gas in der
Nordsee wir haben Gasse in den Böden als
Schiefergas und wenn es zur Zeit hohe
Gaspreise gibt dann ist es auf jeden
Fall richtig zu untersuchen aber warum
sind diese Lösungsvorschläge da nicht
einfach umsetzbar fragt man sich jetzt
also erstmal wir haben einen gestörten
Markt wir haben eine energieschock und
das
verheiratet sich
mit mehr als zehn Jahren verschlafener
Energiepolitik das heißt also wir müssen
in weniger als einem Jahr reparieren was
über zehn Jahre lang so richtig schief
gelaufen ist und das wie gesagt in der
Kombination mit dem Schock dass Russland
nicht mehr liefert der Krieg die
zeitenwände
das bringt uns natürlich schon mächtig
unter Zeitdruck aber jetzt möchte ich
auch mal eine Lanze für die Regierung
brechen wir haben das mit der LNG mit
den beiden NLG terminals in Rekordzeit
hinbekommen das Beschleunigungsgesetz
ist eine Blaupause für weitere ähnliche
Dinge um die Infrastruktur Vorhaben in
Zukunft viel schneller umsetzen zu
können Beschleunigung von Planungs- und
genehmigungsprozessen ist da das
Stichwort und wir haben es immerhin
jetzt auch hinbekommen mit den Grünen
schwer genug haben wir diskutiert eine
Laufzeitverlängerung für die drei AKW
hinzubekommen und auch den Hochlauf von
Kohlekraftwerken das sind alles keine
Herzensangelegenheiten
Herzensanliegen der Grünen Partner
gewesen also
daher sind wir pragmatisch wir sind
schnell aber es sind noch riesige
Aufgaben um in 10 15 Jahren die brauchen
wir nämlich um eine
Wasserstoffwirtschaft hochzufahren und
um tatsächlich Grenzkosten von zwei drei
Cent für die Kilowattstunde Erdgas geht
schnell aus dass wir wissen wo das
Erdgas liegt das könnte man machen habe
ich ja und haben sie zu Recht hier
darauf hingewiesen aber ich wundere mich
schon ich meine sie sind ja
Parlamentarier es ist eine
angekommission eingerichtet worden zum
Untersuchung ob Fracking wirklich
umweltschädlich ist und das Ergebnis
liegt seit einem Jahr dem deutschen
Parlament vor das wird nicht debattiert
dass der Deutsche Bundestag debattiert
das Ergebnis der Experten nicht weil es
unangenehm ist das hat man ganz bewusst
vor dem niedersächsischen Wahlkampf
rausgehalten weil da kommt nicht dann
bei raus dass die Experten sagen das
könnt ihr ruhig machen das kann man
nämlich beherrschen dieses Thema
Fracking in Deutschland besser
jedenfalls hier zu machen als
amerikanisches Fracking Gas zu
importieren und das hat der Deutsche
Bundestag das sind unsere Abgeordneten
nicht noch nicht mal zur Kenntnis
genommen da muss man doch mal wirklich
die Frage stellen die sie vorhin
gestellt haben kann man da wirklich
sagen haben die alles getan was nötig
ist sie sagen nein ja in dieser Frage
zum Beispiel ist ein Versagen des
Deutschen Bundestages da völlig klar und
die Opposition ich frage mich auch wo es
bleibt die denn ich meine da muss doch
mal Frieda
kämpft auf Twitter sehr hart ob das
jetzt was bringt für den Bürger weiß ich
nicht ganz aber auf Twitter sind die
sehr das Problem bei Friedrich Merz ist
doch dass er in seinem eigenen
adenau-haus immer noch die Merkel Jana
einer Überzahl hat und dass er sich
natürlich nicht so durchsetzen kann
offenbar wie es eigentlich nötig wäre
für ein Opposition die müssen doch
getrieben werden die Bundesregierung die
muss dafür einfach noch eine Opposition
die muss doch auch die unangenehm
Wahrheiten auf den Tisch legen das ist
ein Punkt wo ja auch zwischen den beiden
einigkeit herrscht das in den letzten
zehn Jahren nicht alles richtig gemacht
wurde energiepolitisch und jetzt aber zu
Ihnen Herr Konrad ich komme hier
durcheinander drei Brillen drei Männer
die werden mich jetzt endlich wieder
halten die Sache ist ja ganz klar die
die letzten zehn Jahre und auch schon
davor wurden ja Fehler gemacht in der
Energiepolitik ich denke keiner würde
mehr verteidigen dass wir komplett
abhängig von einem Partner waren wie
läuft das beim Bundesnachrichtendienst
wie kann man sich das vorstellen hat man
darauf überhaupt Einfluss ist einem das
schon vorher bewusst geworden dass es
vielleicht Schwierigkeiten gibt ja
sicher das hat auch gestern insofern das
Timing sehr glücklich hat gestern der
BND-Präsident Bruno kahl auch sehr
deutlich in der öffentlichen Anhörung
gesagt wir Bulgur also der BND haben
seit Jahren darauf hingewiesen dass
Sommer Russland ein Problem ein
sicherheitspolitisches geopolitisches
Problem für Europa und eben für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland wird und
schon vor 2014 darauf hingewiesen dass
eine Diversifizierung von
Energiebeschaffung etc pp notwendige
allein nur aus dem
sicherheitspolitischen und darauf wurde
verstärkt hingewiesen dort wurde
kontinuierlich hingemessen ja das heißt
Berichterstattung auch in nd-lagen also
diesen dienstagslagen für die
Staatssekretäre zusammensitzen kann das
immer wieder aber
das nützt gar nichts wenn solche
Informationen und Bewertungen mit dem
penstown-syndrom verbunden werden das
heißt man legt den Stift hin sagt jaja
Reto nur mal das ist durchaus gegeben
das hat der Herr Karl gestern auch
relativ deutlich so als Frau Merkel
darauf reagiert wenn man es mal
personalisieren will frau Merkel sondern
die hat sich erst gar nicht angehört
nicht das sondern es hat eben nichtmals
angehört
man sich den Chef Bundeskanzleramt nicht
oder eben dann den Staatssekretär für
die Nachrichtendienste die uns damals ja
in der Person von Herrn Fritzsche noch
gegeben hat das heißt also die Frage ob
sie mit an welcome News ja mit mit
unangenehmen Informationen ob sie dann
durchdringen oder aber eben durchaus
freundlich nicht auf Abstand gehalten
werden und wenn sie durchdringen denken
Sie daran sie müssten sich dann selbst
wenn sie es zur Kenntnis nehmen müssten
sie ja überlegen was sie mit dieser
Information anfangen das heißt also der
politische Willensbildung ja erst einmal
innerhalb der Exekutive dann aber
müssten sie ja gegebenenfalls die
politisch Willensbildung im Bundestag
oder zusammen mit der Wirtschaft von
Anfang einzuleiten nicht eine Kehrtwende
das wäre natürlich töricht sondern
schlicht und einfach eine stärkere
Diversifizierung geben uns natürlich
auch schon sowas natürlich zum Beispiel
auch andere auch andere Anbieter nochmal
sondieren wir waren früher sehr stark
vom nahen mit Nordosten und Nordafrika
in
Energiezufuhr nicht abhängig aber das
waren gute Zulieferer die haben wir für
Peter nehmen ab Frau Merkel verteidigt
ist ja sogar noch heute also hätte jetzt
auch wieder gesprochen sie das war der
trainiert betrachtet das günstige
Preis-Leistungsverhältnis wenn ich das
richtig sehe nicht so günstig sind wir
wir also Deutschland sonst nie an
Energie gekommen das war so gesehen
schon Erdgas das durch eine Pipeline
fließt ist natürlich immer billiger als
Flüssiggas das hinterher regazifiziert
werden mussten und zwischendurch auch
gelagert und transportiert werden muss
aber es bringt natürlich auf beiden
Seiten Abhängigkeit mit sich also sowohl
des Anbieters als auch des Abnehmers ist
eine Abhängigkeit da weil man die
Pipeline nicht umzügeln kann ja die kann
man nicht woanders hinlegen also es gibt
nur einen Punkt wo es losgeht und ein
paar Punkte wo es daneben
sind jetzt in um geopolitischen Kontexte
nicht mehr erwünscht nein Sie müssen
dringend überwunden werden Russland ist
im übrigen meiner Meinung nach erledigt
da werden wir nichts mehr kaufen
jedenfalls nichts was zwischen drei
kleinen fließt und andere Abhängigkeiten
wie beispielsweise mit China sogar nie
wieder Gas aus Russland ich würde nie
sagen nie wieder genau
das das ist nicht von der Landkarte
verschieben das wird ja da bleiben es
ist ganz voll Rede wenn auch da bleiben
und im Augenblick macht Russland
folgendes sie nehmen von der Yamaha das
ist das Gebiet was uns versorgt eine
Pipeline Richtung China
eine power of Siberia direkt durch die
Mongolei nach China das heißt das wird
gar nicht mehr an uns ob wir überhaupt
haben wollen
haben auch ein Teil dann kannst du
liefern dann das wäre wahrscheinlich
auch langfristig sag mal wenn wir
Frieden haben und sagt man danach Putin
Ära mit Sicherheit nichts dagegen wenn
da aus einer Pipeline Gas nach Europa
wird weil wir dann auch eine
diversifizierte aller Anbieter haben ich
würde auch nicht ungerne ich würde auch
nicht gerne alleine von Amerika abhängig
sein sie müssen wissen per beiden sagt
wir stoppt disstracking und Sie können
Experten befragen die sagen in drei vier
Jahren wird der amerikanische Fracking
Gaspreis so durch die
durch die Wiener Rakete nach oben gehen
ja weil keine neuen Felder mehr
erschlossen werden und was das
amerikanische
amerikanische Präsident dann machen wird
wenn die Gaspreise steigen in Amerika
und die die die die die Benzinpreise
steigen das kann ich Ihnen jetzt schon
verraten der Stopp den Export das wird
das wird so kommen das heißt auch das
ist nicht so etwas wo wir sagen können
die guten Amerikaner die helfen uns dann
schon nee nee das wird genauso ein
Risiko werden einmal noch konkret können
Sie sich vorstellen Einschätzung her
dass die deutsche Industrie ohne
russisches Gas überhaupt auskommen kann
also im Augenblick ist es tatsächlich so
dass wir nur deswegen durchkommen weil
wir diese
Subventionen bekommen und das wird sich
aber
die LNG Importe werden ein Viertel des
russischen Gases ersetzen können das
wird nicht hinten und vorne lang und
deswegen wird die Frage sich natürlich
die Hoffnung ist dass das dieser
Konflikt endlich in eine
friedensrichtung geht damit man auch
wieder vernünftig miteinander reden kann
weil am Ende glaube ich langfristig wäre
es gut wenn wir auch dieses Ei im Korb
hätten und nicht nur in amerikanisches
und algerisches oder sonst wie schlechte
Aussichten für die deutsche Wirtschaft
das ist echt eine gute Überleitung zu
ihrem Thema
heute Abend was sie uns mitgebracht
haben ja ich hatte es ja eben schon mal
gesagt es geht um die internationale
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Wirtschaft
unserer Unternehmen insbesondere das
industriellen Mittelstands der der
exportierenden Industrie und da brauchen
wir einfach Vertrauen in den deutschen
Standort und das ist in Zeiten der
schwersten Energiekrise seit Bestehen
der Bundesrepublik das Thema Nummer eins
wir haben hochlohn Land das ist auch in
gewisser Weise erfreulich dass die
Menschen viele Menschen ordentlich
verdienen wir haben noch eine gute
Infrastruktur naja aber immerhin sie
wird noch geschätzt vielleicht wird sie
zu langsam erneuert wir haben hohe
Steuern hohe Unternehmen steuern das
belastet den Standort jetzt haben wir
die höchsten Energiekosten der Welt und
das können wir uns auf Dauer nicht
erlauben und deswegen sage ich wir
brauchen um die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
deutschen Wirtschaft langfristig zu
stärken nicht nur eine entlast bei den
Energiepreisen eben ist schon gesagt
worden wir haben jetzt einen
industriegaspreis von 7 Cent
gaspreisbremse zeitlich befristet aber
vielleicht geht das langfristig wenn wir
belügend LNG Angebote bekommen auch aus
anderen Regionen kanada gehört auch dazu
finde ich wir haben
auf den Weg gebracht eine
strompreisbremse die ist noch nicht
konkretisiert worden das muss in der
nächsten Tagen folgen ganz wichtiges
Signal für die Wirtschaft und wir
brauchen perspektivisch meiner Meinung
nach auch ein industriestrompreis das
muss ein anderes Marktdesign geben
vielleicht married order ohne den
teuersten muss man mal gucken wie man
das ausgestaltet aber ich erwarte dass
wir als Perspektive für die deutsche
Wirtschaft auch perspektivisch einen
industriestrompreis bekommen so
Entlastung brauchen wir auch bei den
Steuern das beste Instrument sind dabei
übrigens super Abschreibungen erhöhte
Abschreibungen da steht auch im
Koalitionsvertrag das muss spätestens
2024 auf die Schiene gesetzt werden
[Musik]
Beschreibung sind deswegen besser als
Steuersenkungen weil sie sicherstellen
dass die Investitionen hier bei uns
stattfinden und nicht irgendwo auf der
Welt und das dritte
Entlastungspaket das brauchen wir im
Zusammenhang mit der Bürokratie ein
riesiges Paket oh ja wir brauchen viel
schnellere Planung und Genehmigung zu
verfahren kurze Punkte die man sich ganz
komprimiert merken kann super
Abschreibungen in 2024 beschleunigte
Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren
belastungsmoratorium für die Wirtschaft
und industriestrompreis das sind die
Punkte die ich hier auf jeden Fall
fordere Herr fahren heute als ehemaliger
Politiker ja auch das hat ja auch viel
mit Bürokratie zu tun gibt es da
überhaupt eine Chance dass das passieren
wird also dass das geht hat der
kronenbecher dargestellt nicht die LNG
Genehmigung ist innerhalb von drei
Wochen erfolgt und wenn man sozusagen
wir haben gerade über Erdgas Fracking in
Deutschland gemacht das könnte man auch
in drei Monaten machen da das heißt also
wir müssen jetzt eigentlich
der Politik klar machen dass sie das was
an Beschleunigung da ist zum generellen
Standard in Deutschland macht aber da
stellen wir eben doch fest dass ich
meine das sagen wir heute Abend aber das
Thema ist nicht wirklich
eingefühl wirklich in den in den
Ministerien der Regierung angekommen das
ist da ist kein Wille da der
Wirtschaftsminister hat viel zu tun um
in
Saudi-Arabien und den in Katar das zu
viel gebracht ne eben das das Erdgas
kaputt zu machen und mal ganz deutlich
zu sagen hat den nämlich gesagt
eigentlich wollen wir gar keine Erdgas
langfristig weil wir wollen ja aus dem
Erdgas raus und dann hatten die Katars
gesagt ja schönen Dank und haben es an
die Italiener vergeben so erfolgreich
war er da und er wird auch nichts tun um
das zu beschleunigen das ist den Grünen
sozusagen nicht nicht geheuer wenn
schnelle Prozesse passieren und Sie
haben ja eine industriefeindlichkeit an
sich deswegen
ich bin auch enttäuscht von den
Verbänden nicht die müssen viel mehr
Druck machen die Gewerkschaften müssen
in Berlin antreten und sagen wir
brauchen jetzt eine Initiative für die
Industrie ich habe selbst eine
Initiative jetzt auf dem Weg gebracht
rettet unsere Industrie das können sie
googeln da können Sie sich einen
Aufkleber an ihr Auto machen ja soweit
kommt das noch weil diese Verbände wie
eine Lehmschicht zwischen den wirklichen
Problemen des Mittelstands stecken und
der Politik und nichts durchlassen und
deswegen brauchen wir das auf jeden
Aufkleber auf jeden auf jedem Auto denn
atomkraft nein danke das war gestern und
jetzt heißt es rettet unseren Wohlstand
rettet die Industrie da mir eigentlich
viele immer große Hoffnungen in FDP sind
sie denn enttäuscht von der FDP ja die
SPD die FDP hat glaube ich sich an ein
Jahr lang einlullen lassen und dafür hat
sie die Quittung in drei Land das waren
bekommen sie hat
furios gestartet hat viele Dinge wie zum
Beispiel die die die Steuererklärung
verhindern
aber dann ist auch nichts mehr gekommen
und da kommt die Quittung und die muss
jetzt sich zum Anwalt der Arbeitsplätze
machen zum Anwalt der Industrie ich
schicke einen Lindner gerne diesen
Aufkleber
den Aufkleber auch haben was sagen Sie
jetzt mit dem Vorwurf dass sie sich ein
Jahr lang haben eindollen lassen
also das kann ich so das teile ich so
nicht
Überraschung gewesen ja schauen sie
werden gerade heute gesprochen über den
Neubau der Talbrücke A45 bei Lüdenscheid
ein riesen 10 Jahre ein zehn-jahresthema
wäre das normalerweise gewesen acht bis
zehn Jahre war die Prognose dann hat man
gesagt ah wenn man das machen wenn wir
das machen dann schaffen das vielleicht
in fünf Jahren jetzt sind wir inzwischen
bei 4 Jahren und das alles ist sozusagen
ich bin auch nicht sicher ob das das
Ende der Fahnenstange ist weil ich
optimistisch bin dass wir mit einer
Vertragsausgestaltung wo eine schnellere
Fertigstellung belohnt wird sogar unter
die vier Jahre kommen können also da ist
einiges passiert und das ist gut so und
das verdanken wir den
Wirtschaftsminister Quatsch stimmt
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing er wäre
besser Wirtschaftsminister nicht das war
der frontschiff versichert
48 Millionen Menschen freuen sich dass
sie nächstes Jahr auf dem weniger
Steuern zahlen bzw die gleichen steuern
aber der kaufpreisverlust durch die
Inflation ausgeglichen wird also da ist
einiges möglich es wäre vielleicht mehr
möglich gewesen wenn wir schon mit einem
krisenmodus in die Regierungsarbeit
gegangen werden aber noch mal wir haben
eine Zeitenwende wir haben eine
Zeitenwende seit dem 24 februar über
später darüber diskutieren würde ich
sogar sagen wahrscheinlich schon zu
Beginn der Olympischen Winterspiele die
gemeinsame Erklärung von China und
Russland das war für mich eigentlich
schon der Auslöser für die zeitenwände
die wir haben und darauf war niemand
vorbereitet das gebe ich offen zu ja
wenn man sich den Koalitionsvertrag
durchliest was da alles drin steht auch
zu ihren täten Geheimdienste das hat
nichts zu tun mit den Anforderungen den
wir uns Herausforderung den den wir uns
heute stellen
nachvollziehen dass die Bürger sich
überhaupt nicht mehr abgeholt fühlen sie
hören wie Politiker die Regierungsarbeit
loben während sie sich Angst um ihre
Energiekosten machen wie sie teilweise
ihre mietet sein sollen das Bürger sich
vielleicht allein gelassen fühlen
aktuell
wir haben drei entlastungspakete auf den
Weg gebracht mit einem Gesamtvolumen von
95 Milliarden Euro wir haben mit dem
Abwehrschirm auch einen finanziellen
Rahmen geschaffen von bis zu 200
Milliarden Euro um all die Maßnahmen die
jetzt die Gaspreise eindämmen und auch
die Strompreise annehmen werden zu
finanzieren das ist schon sehr sehr
selbst einkaufen
ja also nicht so nicht zu häufig nicht
so häufig
das Quark oder Butter kostet würden sie
es wissen nein aber Butter ist deutlich
teurer geworden deutlich aber wenn Sie
den Preis wissen also ich habe immer
einen guten Euro bezahlt das dürfte in
Euro 50 Euro 60 jetzt anführen
ja
ich denke wenn ich ihn einen Tipp geben
darf als Moderatorin geht sie morgen
meinen Supermarkt einkaufen und schauen
Sie was die Bürger zahlen wenn sie das
machen würdest würde mich sehr freuen
also Inflation ist die größte Bedrohung
für Wohlstand und Arbeitsplätze selber
meine Supermarkt gehen weil damit kommen
sie nicht mehr hin wenn wir aber mit der
Gießkanne Geld verteilen dann heizen wir
Inflation an das ist ein Problem dass
wir nicht lösen können mit fiskalischen
Maßnahmen das können wir nur durch
höhere Produktivität in der Wirtschaft
und deswegen fordere ich ja all diese
Dinge die ich gefordert habe damit
Investitionen kommen um die
Produktivität zu steigern um
Arbeitsplätze noch besser zu bezahlen
bezahlen zu können und dann gleichzeitig
bei Steuerentlastung dann kommen wir
dahin dass wir Inflation auch wieder in
den Griff bekommen aber Inflation ist
fürchterlich und sie gehen einkaufen
wir Konrad wissen Sie denn was zuletzt
das Päckchen Butter 1 Euro oder 1,50 €
gekostet hat ist ja ziemlich lange her
also ich kenne die aktuellen Preise nur
229 das günstigste Angebot nicht nur
dass ich also gut dass ich jetzt
vielleicht nicht bei Aldi sondern ich
gehe alles selber machen
45 für Kerrygold gezahlt ja
hausfrauentag nicht ja genau
ich denke das ist wichtig weil das ist
ja das was ein jedes mal selber
schockiert wenn man einkaufen wird das
ursprünglich butterpreises das ist schon
richtig jetzt überall überhaupt schon
mal ein paar Monate gelaufen nicht von
heute auf morgen aber das nützt uns
jetzt nichts ich meinte die Preise sind
sind nur noch was für wohlhabende
Menschen Herr fahren heute sie selber
haben ja wenn man das so ausdrücken darf
kommen sie aus einfacheren Verhältnissen
als sie heute leben was hätten denn zum
Beispiel ihre Eltern gesagt wenn
Politiker nicht mehr wissen was ein
Päckchen Butter kostet das weiß ich
jetzt nicht das was meine Eltern dazu
gesagt hätten aber ich ich weiß ja wohl
wie sie damals jeden jede mag umdrehen
mussten und deswegen kann ich es auch
gut nachvollziehen und wir Sie wenn man
dann noch von der Politik dann so so
Formel Sprüche hört wie
Waschlappen oder andere Dinge nicht oder
zwei Pullover übereinander ziehen
dann dann die Bevölkerung die wirklich
kämpfen muss die weiß am 20 schon nicht
mehr da geht dann das der
kontokorrentkontritt gelöst ja da geht
dann das Negative Konto los weil das war
der Lohn nicht mehr ausreicht um die
entsprechenden
Kostensteigerung abzudecken es ist
schrecklich wenn ein Bundesminister sagt
ich weiß nicht wie das der Liter Benzin
kostet das ist das was uns alle jeden
Tag interessiert und da muss man dann
sagen ihr Punkt unser
Landwirtschaftsminister herr Özdemir hat
gesagt wir wollen jetzt eigentlich die
Felder verknappen wir wollen den wir
wollen Lebensmittel weniger Lebensmittel
produzieren indem wir überall
ökologischen Landbau machen und und
Lebensmittel müssen teurer werden das
ist Hohn in den Ohren unserer Bürger
und da müsste er mal hinkommen sein tut
mir leid das habe ich alles nicht so
kommen sehen und wir machen jetzt mal
diesen ganzen Unfug nicht mehr im
Augenblick mal sehen dass wir aus jeder
jedem Hektar Land auch wirklich
Lebensmittel bekommen und damit auch
eine Kostendämpfung hinkriegen mehr
Demut das wünschen sich viele Politiker
in diesem Land von der Politik und wir
machen eine ganz kurze Unterbrechung und
sind wieder zurück
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter bauen und
ich ernst nehmen als sogenannten
Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei 8:15 Uhr fünf Köpfen fünf
Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat uschiffen
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grünen roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die
rettungsweltklimas und um die Füße rum
wuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig uns nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz Einsatz
also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken so ich habe
meinen Beifall in meiner lache immer
bekommen wer kümmert sich darum niemand
bitte ist Baden ja man muss da ganz klar
jetzt mal auch darüber sprechen dass es
einfach nicht fair ist und nicht richtig
durch die Aufgabe von Journalismus
einfach die die Verlautbarung der
Politik zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück schön dass Sie dran
geblieben sind und wir machen weiter mit
der These von Frau melnikolter an
ich würde ich glaube damit anfangen dass
wir dass das was mir jetzt seit langem
am Herzen liegt nämlich
das wir in Deutschland sehr häufig über
realpolitische Ansätze diskutieren und
es gibt auch einige Stimmen die davon
überzeugt sind dass man wirklich die
Ukraine
zu den Verhandlungen zwingen soll und
ich habe das Gefühl man ist wirklich
nicht bereit neue Ansätze auszuarbeiten
und klebt sehr stark an realpolitischen
Ansätzen die nicht mehr
zeitgemäß sind und manchmal habe ich
auch das Gefühl man möchte einfach den
Status Quo aufrecht erhalten und ist
nicht bereit für sozusagen die
Beziehungen als zu Russland zu ändern
und versuche sie wirklich aufrecht zu
erhalten und ich habe das Gefühl man
muss wirklich offener sein und außen
politische einfach Strategie mit Blick
auf Russland überdenken und sich
wirklich Gedanken und zum Teil auch von
Russland zu verabschieden
und was ich auch
mir wünschen würde dass man ganz genau
weiß welche Zukunft man für die Ukraine
oder welche Zug und man mit der Ukraine
sieht wenn ich es einmal konkret machen
darf sie fühlen sich also sagen die
Ukraine ist vom Westen im Stich gelassen
was finden sie denn was Deutschland
konkret noch stärker tun kann wir haben
ja beispielsweise Wirtschaftssanktionen
beschlossen die unser Land hart treffen
wir befinden uns im energiekrieg also
Deutschland leidet die Wirtschaft leidet
die Bürger leiden wo würden Sie denn
sagen was Deutschland zu wenig Macht ich
würde nicht sagen dass die Ukraine jetzt
sich in Stich gelassen fühlen das würde
ich das finde ich ein bisschen
übertrieben weil eigentlich das muss man
schon auch sagen der Westen hat viel
gemacht und ohne Westen wird die Ukraine
auch den alleine nicht siegen ich glaube
es ist wichtig sich vor der Russland zu
verabschieden wir denken immer dass wenn
Putin nicht weiter an der Macht ist oder
wäre dann können wir wiederum die
Beziehungen mit Russland aufbauen und
das ist
wir glauben nicht daran dass die auch
die kollektive Verantwortung für all
dieser Kriegsverbrechen die jetzt sind
in der Ukraine stattfinden dass wir
diese Verbrechen auch die Gesellschaft
die Verantwortung tragen soll und wir
sprechen in der Öffentlichkeit in der
öffentlichen Debatten weniger darüber
wie wir eigentlich das butische Regime
zu Verantwortung ziehen können sozusagen
wir und das finde ich immer spannend
dass man vergisst überall diese
Kriegsverbrechen man möchte wiederum die
Beziehungen auf ja so wie immer hatten
haben aber und ist bereit eigentlich
auch die Kriegsverbrechen die Augen zu
tun aber wir haben uns ja eigentlich von
Russland verabschiedet wo haben wir das
noch nicht getan in der politischen
Debatten habe ich nicht das Gefühl dass
wir uns davon verabschiedet haben haben
Sie ein konkretes Beispiel ich glaube
das ist eher so all diese öffentliche
Diskussion die wir haben
und das ist eine gute Frage auch an die
Politik ich habe das Gefühl wir sind im
Modus des Abwartens was passiert danach
und es gibt auch so kleine Zeichen wenn
man zum Beispiel sagt immer ja das ist
der putinische Krieg aber nicht der
russische Krieg oder wir sprechen von
Ukraine Krieg aber nicht vom sozusagen
russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine das
alles hat Konsequenzen und ich muss
sagen das ist wir werden auch das Sehen
nach dem Winter nach all dieser
Inflation ob auch die und deutsche
Gesellschaft bereit wäre weiterhin
diesen Preis zu zahlen und die Politik
ist schon gefragt auch stärker zu
kommunizieren womit wir zu tun haben die
die deutsche Politik das muss man
ehrlich sagen ist vor allem auch dafür
gewählt Schaden vom deutschen Volk
abzuwenden da ist natürlich dann auch
die Frage die man stellen muss ist die
Politik da nicht auch irgendwann auch
Anwalt der deutschen Bürger ich verstehe
Anliegen sehr gut aber die Frage die ich
da noch gerne an Sie stellen würde ist
die Politik ob sie das nachvollziehen
kann die Politik muss natürlich abwägen
Zuwendung für die Ukraine und deutsche
Bürger ja so so sehe ich sehe ich das
auch aber
damit womit wir heute konfrontiert sind
das ist nicht nur der Ukraine Krieg und
damit ist nicht nur die Ukraine
konfrontiert sondern wir als Westen und
wenn wir das Trennen werden und sagen
dass eigentlich trifft uns nicht dann
haben sie recht aber das trifft uns alle
aber wenn wir so umgegangen wären oder
will man mit uns so umgegangen wäre nach
dem dritten Reich so nach dem Motto mit
denen das sind die Parias mit denen
werden wir nie wieder was zu tun haben
wollen sie müssen doch zumindest die
Chance geben dass das Russland sich auch
sozusagen entwickeln kann dass man mit
dem jetzigen Regime kann ich viel
verständlicher finden aber ich finde sie
können auch nicht sagen der Russe an
sich ist schlecht oder so
im Augenblick ist da alles sind sind
diplomatische
Erziehung nicht angesagt aber es muss
doch unsere Hoffnung sein dass wir auch
mit solchen Völkern in Zukunft wieder
friedlich zusammenarbeiten die Ukraine
auch nicht eigentlich weil eigentlich
die Ukraine ist das Land das was an
Russland grenzt und die Ukraine möchte
auch konstruktiver Beziehungen haben
aber es geht jetzt darum aber
verhandelnde selensky aktuell nicht
richtig die Frage ist worüber können wir
behandeln und ich sehe auch gar keine
Möglichkeit das Russland jetzt behandeln
will ganz ehrlich
immer gibt es da gab es aber danach
Erfolg der Butcher und danach erfolgte
auch viele andere schreckliche
Geschichten und ich glaube da kann man
nicht einfach sagen wir machen die Augen
zu und es ist uns egal dass die Menschen
hier massakriert wurden kommen wir noch
einmal auf das Verhältnis zu Schaden von
deutschen Volk abzuwenden und die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine weil da
haben sie auch richtig eingeworfen Frau
Merkel muss man eigentlich auch mal die
Politik fragen wie gehen Sie damit um
weil es ist ja schon Spannungsfeld nö so
Putin greift die Ukraine an aber er
meint uns
er meint unsere Freiheit er meint unsere
Demokratie unseren Stil zu leben das was
andere Völker attraktiv finden wo die
auch hin wollen und wo die mitmachen
wollen er meint die EU er meint
vielleicht auch die NATO aber ich sehe
überhaupt keinen Gegensatz und wenn er
uns auch meint wie weit würden Sie also
gehen
ja ich bin durchaus der Meinung dass wir
schwere Waffen in die Ukraine liefern
können das verkürzt das Leid und den
Krieg ich bin da der Auffassung wie die
Vorsitzende des Verteidigungsausschusses
meine Parteifreundinnen
aber ich muss auch sagen dass ich
Respekt habe vor den Entscheidungen die
der Bundeskanzler fällt und trifft weil
ihm auch immer mehr Informationen
vorliegen als mir als Abgeordneten ich
möchte einen anderen Aspekt da
reinbringen im Moment gibt es keine
Grundlage für eine militäre für eine für
ein Regimewechsel in Moskau es brauchte
militärische Niederlage die kann kommen
es braucht aber auch eine
wirtschaftliche Niederlage es braucht
auch Druck
bestenfalls von den Oligarchen und der
Militär ich glaube am Ende wird es nur
ollige
ich lasse mich nicht erpressen okay also
auch wenn selbst bist
Atomwaffen da gibt es taktische Waffen
und strategische Waffen und die
taktischen Waffen ich gehe davon aus
dass das passieren kann dass sie
eingesetzt werden die haben aber nur
einen lokalen
kommen wir das sollte eine sehr galante
Überleitung sein zu dem Thema von Herr
Konrad heute Abend damit wir auch für
Sie genügend Zeit noch haben weil sie
beschäftigen sich ja genau damit
ja gut also wir beschäftigen uns heute
die Nachrichtendienste beschäftigen sich
im Wesentlichen mit lagerfeststellungen
lagebohrt das heißt also jetzt konkret
auch auf die Ukraine bezogen geht es
natürlich das können Sie nicht nur beim
BND der macht das nicht zu öffentlich
die Briten und die Amerikaner da können
sie im tägliche Militärs lesen die gar
nicht schlecht sind ne oder gönnerhaft
zu sagen ich war da steht auch nur die
Hälfte drin logischerweise der Rest ist
eben nicht für publikon Sunshine aber
wiederum kann ich mich sehr schön auf
die Gäste hier öffentliche Anhörung
beziehen und da wird auch sehr klar und
hat der Karl sehr klar gesagt wir
schließen den Einsatz von taktischen
Nuklearwaffen in der Ukraine nicht aus
es ist derzeit nicht konkret absehbar es
ist klar das muss man auch sagen Herr
Putin selbst möchte eigentlich auch
überleben ja und möchte diese Form der
vertikalen Eskalation mit potenziell
unabsehbaren Folgen die steht ganz
hinten er droht damit das ist ganz klar
um einfach die Hürden für eine konse
Unterstützung der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte und der Ukraine eben so
hoch wie möglich zu setzen aber was wir
erwarten müssen erst einmal den nächsten
Monaten ist was ich vorhin erwähnte wenn
man nicht im Felde Erfolg hat aus
russischer Sicht dann geht man eben in
die Weg der Horizontalen Eskalation und
horizontale Eskalation heißt also es
wird eben wie jetzt gerade auch
geschehen wird der Ukraine nach
Möglichkeit ein kalter Winter beschert
ein Winter der Entbehrungen und zugleich
wird man so etwas auch erwägen
gegenüber Deutschland halten sie atomare
Eskalation für möglich für
unwahrscheinlich hochschwellig ja das
heißt also nichts was wir in den
nächsten Wochen oder Monaten ohne eine
weitere Lageveränderung erwarten müssen
jetzt wird erst einmal versucht mit
denen jetzt absehbaren Mitteln einfach
den Willen das muss man sein das ist ja
der Punkt den Willen des Gegners in dem
Fall also dann primär erstmal der
Ukraine aber dann auch von Unterstützer
starten ja zu beugen wenn es geht zu
brechen wenn man im Felde nicht
weiterkommt Zeit zu kaufen denn ich
meine sie merken ja auch
Unterstützungsleistungen werden ja auch
von Russland nicht auch so netten
Staaten wie Iran oder eben auch
weißrussland ist herangezogen die Russen
müssen mit Sicherheit zwei drei vier
Monate noch berechnen um wie das sich
mit wenigstens Verbrauchsmaterial
einigermaßen einzudecken militärischen
etc ist nicht so schnell produziert
werden können aber das Theater leider
das traurige Theater wird absehbar
weitergehen
da putin wird da jetzt die Chance
zu fassen sie halten die atomare
Eskalation gerade nicht für das letzte
Mittel das letzte Mittel der Krieg wird
weitergehen und Verhandlungen sind
erstmal nicht in Sicht
so einfach ist das solange beide Seiten
solange beide Seiten den das Ergebnis
auf dem Felde erzielen wollen aber es
ist ja furchtbar wenn man überlegt wie
viel Soldaten auf beiden Seiten sterben
ja also es heißt der Krieg kann sich
auch noch fünf Jahre lang ziehen
auch das kann man das ist jetzt so lange
dass man das nicht seriös
druckgussisieren kann ja aber auf eine
absehbare Zeit das ist halt ein
abnutzungskrieg das heißt der derzeit
wird immer noch darauf spekuliert auch
gerade auch von russischer Seite wir
haben so viel wenn Sie wollen wir haben
so viel geopolitische geostrategisches
Hinterland wenn Sie wollen ja wir
brauchen Zeit ja wir haben Ressourcen
wir sind zwar
einigermaßen unterlegen ja im taktisch
unterlegen aber wir können das durch
Masse ausgleichen und wir haben unter
dem Aspekte längeren Atem das wird
wahrscheinlich soweit das erkennen
können die Philosophie sein wir haben
erst einmal den längeren militärischen
Atem und die Frage ist bloß wie wirken
sich die wirtschaftlichen
Einschränkungen
gegenüber Russland dann auch
demoralisierend auch für die Elite aus
da gibt es erste Zeichen dass man nicht
so sehr begeistert ist
was heute noch gar nicht absehbar ist
ist ob das jetzt wirklich Substantiv ich
würde gerne einmal bei dem
wirtschaftlichen Aspekten mal bleiben
und erfahren halt fragen wie lange wie
kann es denn Deutschland wirtschaftlich
überhaupt aushalten
das kommt auf das Niveau der Zerstörung
an die wir akzeptieren wollen wenn sie
natürlich
eine eine Fortsetzung des Konfliktes
über Jahre haben und wir unsere
industrielle Basis zerstört haben dann
reden wir mal so eben über einige
Millionen Arbeitsplätze aber deswegen
darf man glaube ich nie die Hoffnung
aufgeben dass es immer wieder auch
Zeiten gibt indem man einen
diplomatisches Fenster nutzen muss ich
glaube das kann man nicht einfach nach
dem Motto sagen
wir müssen jetzt
Russland besiegen das heißt die Frage
ist wer hält das länger durch das fällt
eine Diktatur immer länger durch als in
Demokratie und es ist noch gar nicht
ausgemacht ob bei der mit terms in einem
Monat
die Republikaner den die Mehrheit im
Kongress und dem Senat haben und wenn
Sie Herrn Trump hören und er sagte ich
hätte den Krieg sehr schnell beendet ich
werde so Pudding hingefahren mit dem
beendet und wir wissen das wäre
wahrscheinlich zulassen
wahrscheinlich der der Ukraine getroffen
wäre aber
das ist zumindest auch etwas was wir
bedenken müssen wir sind nicht alleine
auf der Welt und die Amerikaner gucken
schon die Republikaner sehen schon dass
es am Ende nicht auf Dauer sein kann
dass Sie jeden Monat 10 Milliarden
rüberschicken nicht meine die haben ja
Gott sei Dank für Sie aus ihrer Sicht
nicht die Zerstörung die wir zu haben
ich meine wenn es darf immer nicht
vergessen ich habe vorhin von 50
Milliarden die uns die Stromkosten nicht
das würde man ja gerne für
Entwicklungshilfe ausgeben oder für
unsere eigene Bürger ja jeder
Arbeitsplatz der hier verzerstört wird
kostet auch am Ende
Wohlstand und und wird hier gerne eine
noch einmal noch mal Frau Menning Fragen
hängt es denn dann mehr eigentlich an
dem amerikanischen Präsidenten als an
Deutschland ich würde nicht sagen das
hängt wirklich am Besten vom Besten ab
und ich muss sagen der Westen das ist
aber Amerika ist der größere Hebel ja
aber der Westen an sich ist kein
einziger Staat und wenn wir als
Gemeinschaft der die eigentlich aus
mehreren Staaten besteht nicht in der
Lage sind ein Einfluss auf ein
autoritären Staat auszuüben was können
wir dann und ich glaube der nächste
Punkt ich habe das Gefühl wir beurteilen
immer Russland als ob Russland immer aus
der Position der Stärke agiert und die
Ukraine aus der Position der Schwäche
immer am Anfang ich glaube viele wurden
überrascht dass die Ukraine dann mehr
als drei Tage durchgehalten hat und das
ist ein großer Irrtum ich glaube nicht
nur wir sollen diesen Winter überstehen
wir sollen auch schauen wie ihr
eigentlich Russland das Meistern wird
womit wir alle glaube ich hier jetzt am
Ende der Sendung einer Meinung sind ist
dieser Krieg hoffentlich bald endet wir
wünschen Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
und wenn Sie mögen sind sie doch morgen
abend wieder dabei danke schön tschüss
[Musik]